foreign
I'm getting out of here next week served
my time I heard you've been telling
people the first thing you were going to
do when you walk out of here is get a
gun look me up
never killed nobody that wasn't trying
to kill me
stay clear of me Joe you do the same
otherwise
most likely you're dead man
Senor Max Portland is a private
investigator I wouldn't try anything
foolish walk away from that gun Joe
cribbons wait no he's a dangerous man
whole life I've done impulsive things
don't always work out Mr Borland I doubt
that you're familiar familiar with
private Elijah Jones he's taken a white
woman my wife Rachel Elijah nobody if
she would Elijah it's because she want
to be I am willing to offer you two
thousand dollars to bring Rachel back we
did what we done
we just saying all of them
go straight to hell
forget this white woman don't let
nothing interfere with what's good for
Lonzo Mr Borland
are you under the impression that you
are rescuing me your husband is on his
way here I am to watch over you until he
arrives when my husband gets here he
intends to kill me
you lock me up to burial Vargas might
not like it one damn bit just becomes
angry it could be trouble are you
getting nervous
like being lied and I don't like being
used
I guess it's time
see how good you really are
maybe the easiest way out of this mass
is to shoot you
who the hell are you I'm the fella with
the gun most men are afraid to beat me
at cars you will follow orders
[Music]
[Music]
oh
you see this Esteban
you put a gun in it
and it's the devil's right hand